Adam were here to talk about your latest
film adult children of divorce great
title a comedy and I believe you are
yourself one of the children of divorce
I am a child of divorce and thank you
for calling me a child so how did that
help you kind of get into the mindset of
the character for the film um well you
know I grew up with parents on opposite
sides of the town and kind of went back
and forth they were very they got along
perfectly and I had an incredibly happy
childhood unlike the character in the
movie but I certainly related to the
sort of idea of growing up and not quite
knowing what marriage meant to me just
because you know even though it wasn't
completely healthy upbringing I didn't
the main kind of marriage in my life was
broken apart when I was really little so
I sort of related to my character Carter
sort of trying to navigate and and come
to terms with what it is he actually
feels about marriage and whether it's
for him or not now of course it's very
different than maybe some other divorce
dramas who scene because it's a comedy
it's not like the kind of Kramer vs
Kramer tacky taking here so how
important was that to you to inject that
comedy in them it was important i mean
the script was hilarious so if I
couldn't bring comedy to it I would be
failing the script but i think you know
i always go back to flirting with
disaster as a perfect family comedy
comedy about family not necessarily
appropriate for all members of the
family and and i think we were sort of
reaching for that sort of feeling with
this one that these people are insane
but we all understand them perfectly
because we all know them
so we were kind of you know hoping to
achieve something similar to that now as
long as yourself you got a great cost in
there's Jessica Alba isn't know there's
Jane Lynch you've worked with on party
down of course of glee as well what Amy
Poehler in there as well he of course
you've worked with also on Parks and Rec
I'm feeling there's a theme here yeah
yeah were we were lucky to get all these
great people to do and Richard Jenkins
whom I worked with on step brothers he's
just so amazing so we're we were so
lucky to get all these people and and
they they certainly make me look better
so I'm all for it now invention day me
that of course as I said you worked
together on parks and rec and because we
see him season five you've got you've
got engaged you've got married how's
that been great it was great we were it
was such a happy occasion we felt like a
real wedding I mean you put even though
it's fake you put up a little thing you
everyone has flowers you exchange vows
and everyone's crying even though it's a
fake wedding we all were totally crying
and it was it was wonderful it's a great
day now I'm hoping that there aren't
going to be children of divorce for Ben
and Leslie what do you think future
holds for though oh I don't think these
do all ever you can't pry them apart
they were made for each other kids in
the future then I don't know I that
would be that would be that would be
that would be great I have no idea we
have a season six that's what everyone
wants to do I hope so it would be a huge
bummer if there was not a season six do
you like to see happen um you know I
kind of just always let that leave that
in the writers hands because they're a
perfect group of writers and they always
come up with the best anything I think
of they always there their ideas are way
better they are fantastic on then you're
actually working on something else at
the moment the secret life of walter
mitty also a great cast in that as well
what's that like it's great I haven't
seen it yet but the little bits i have
seen are pretty incredible it comes out
christmas day I don't know if it comes
out christmas day over here but yeah
it's Ben Stiller Kristen Wiig Sean Penn
Shirley MacLaine Kathryn Hahn just this
great cast
Patton Oswalt's in it it's it's I think
it's going to be a great movie and we
talked about how you work on related in
a way to your character in acod do you
relate in any way to that kind of
awesome missy carrot and that's not your
character in it but the kind of day
dreamer you a daydreamer oh yeah for
sure for sure I when I was a kid my
family all called me space cadet because
I was always just off in another world
so yeah that's why I found the script
for Walter Mitty so moving and and
lovely because I directly related to it
we look forward to all the projects and
loads of lit with a CID great film
really funny like to meet you much
you